عاصفه قضائيه وسياسيه بطلها دونالد ترامب
الذي يحاول مع اقتراب موعد حملته الرئاسيه
الثالثه اتباع استراتيجيه قانونيه جديده
لمواجهه التحقيقات والاتهامات التي تطاله
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ومع التقدم
التحقيقات بات يستخدم تكتيكات التشتيت
التي تعتمد على المماطله وتشويه سمعه
المدعين العامين واللجوء ايضا الى القاعده
الجمهوريه وفق تقرير صادر عن وستري جورنال
تحدثت فيه الصحيفه مع مساعدين حاليين
وسابقين لترامب الصحيفه دللت على هذا
التكتك بتصعيد ترامب لهجومه على المدعي
العام لمحكمه منهاتان خصوصا وان قرارها قد
يؤدي الى اعتقاله في قضيه جنائيه وهي
سابقه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
ومن تكساس هجم المحققين ووصف نفسه بانه
ضحيه وقال ان تسليح نظام العداله هو
القضيه المركزيه في العصر الحالي ووفق
التقرير قام ترامب بتشكيل مجموعه تضم
مستشارين قانونيين ومحامين ساعيا لتاجيل
الاجراءات القضائيه ومهاجمه اي تهم محتمله
لكن الفريق يفتقر للتنسيق والتنظيم امر
نفاه محامي ترامبا السابق هذا الامر تطرقت
اليه مجله فرنسيه التي اشارت الى ان سجلات
لجنه الانتخابات الفيدراليه اظهرت بان
لجنه العمل السياسيه التابعه للترامب دفعت
اكثر من 16 مليون دولار في رسوم
الاستشارات القانونيه عامي 2021
و2022 ذهب اكثر من نصفها الى شركات مرتبطه
بالمحامين الذين يمثلون ترامب في تحقيقات
مختلفه وفي وقت يواجه فيه ترامب العديد من
القضايا ينفي انصاره كل هذه الاتهامات
التي وصفوها بالقضايا السياسيه اكثر من
كونها قانونيه